thank you thank you all so much for
coming in I super appreciate it thank
you so I want to start with the most
important question I think does Jeff
Bezos watch your show because I figure
he is the one who would like greet you
know he has the ability to I heard make
things with him a lot but I realize I
haven't asked him that question
push that one season two because we
won't let him at a party about the show
and you could tell from the conversation
that he'd seen it the mic that's not
even making it up that's actually true
wait but I mean that doesn't mean that
more than that but it also like so I
know that with a lot of this with
streaming a lot of times they're very
careful Amazon Netflix all the companies
they don't like revealing stuff but I
was so happy that you guys got a second
season because the truth is they had
canceled a lot of their shows and I was
super nervous that it was not going to
get picked up so I'm just throwing out
there I don't know where I was throwing
out there but I'm just super happy you
guys got a second season the answer is
yes absolutely
what going into season two I am curious
you obviously think about the arc and
what you want to do how much from when
you first started thinking about it to
what people are gonna see on screen how
much did it change along the way or was
it always what you were envisioning you
know what I mean
from the beginning yeah when you thought
about season two and what you wanted to
accomplish it went through a lot of
living change I think that the core
ideas remain the same all the way
throughout which we're essentially the
ticking Arthur get to start to be
superheroes in the city the city starts
to become an up and running superhero
kind of place everything just gets up
and moving all the characters step into
the next phase of their sort of ensemble
and family hood but along the way it
came to pass that we ended up in a lot
of rewrites the the storylines the brain
and just the sort of way that reality
met the making of this required a lot of
on-going rewriting so it became actually
in terms of evolution it became a
collaborative project for I think
everybody to sort of sit down on every
day's shooting and kind of sit down with
the material we're going to do and add
to it almost every day the good news is
I we're very close to locking down a
final draft for Episode one yes what you
will see one or two passes away for the
tenth episode but one of the things
about making the show is and a lot of
people might not think about it there's
like an infrastructure where how much
can you accomplish in your seven-day
shoot you're a tation of course how many
VFX shots are you allowed to do what did
you learn on the first season that you
applied to the second season because
obviously I'm sure there's that learning
curve yes you know I mean from the
making of it I would say any time we
have a special effect make it add to the
characters make it be of or for the
characters like like the season before
it was had moments of spectacle that
were kind of just spectacle which was
fun but it was better when those moments
were turned for one of the characters
that we care about and that like
actually was part of a sort of shift in
operating philosophy maybe that's a bit
heady it was okay oh this is a bit heavy
for the actors
I really enjoyed I've seen we I'm gonna
run this after release and I've seen
most of the season and I I thought all
of you guys had great arcs this season
talk a little bit about when you are the
arc of the season and what you really
enjoyed doing with the season this post
is a post release yes yes what so my
question is Prabha
no no the question was no I'll look I'll
be honest with you it wasn't the
it was hardly a question it was like
talk about still yeah no no I fully by
the way I own it I I really nicer I'm
amazed that I have this job every day ya
know I'm I'm not strolling let's repeat
the question now after the fact this
being released post release what what is
the thing we enjoyed most about the
complete Ark of our character right yeah
yeah nicely done still doesn't make it
any easier to answer Arthur Arthur is a
very nervous character and I'm a very
nervous person and I think the
interesting arc was to try to hit a zone
of a little more comfort you know like
Arthur has to hit like cruising altitude
in terms of figuring out how to make
this like sustainable for the rest of
his life this relationship in this
career and all his relationships and all
of that so it was like trying to find a
way to coast into a character that's
more comfortable when it felt like the
work I was doing in season 1 was so
largely defined by being panicked and
terrified about everything that was
going on you want to make Arthur a
little more confident without making him
I don't know not Arthur anymore when you
get recognized and flirted with by
pretty girls you completely just like it
looks like you're seeing Jackie Earle
Haley like Haley again it's a very
deliberate choice I made throughout the
season anytime there's a character we're
talking about real life but I think
Arthur I cannot process the idea that
someone would be attracted to him so
every time it's met with like skepticism
nice to him what is your game yeah I
think he looks cute did you see his butt
for overkill III like that he
he actually gets to a point where he
even not only does he actually care for
and have feelings for other people some
of these people he actually gets to a
point where he might even acknowledge
that actually like possibly you know let
people know that he actually cares
whether they live or die or not so for
me that was that was the tea bag
whatever he just did I
I feel tremendously gratified by what
what we accomplished with that this
season because you know it's been an
ongoing conversation between Ben and I
from the very beginning of the series
about his desire to to subvert the the
role that dot has traditionally played
and that that sort of archetype plays
within the genre it's just the
supportive kind of emotional ground in
the caretaker you know and automatically
being relegated to that role in this
very Lake male-dominated world and genre
and it's something that you know we
didn't know I didn't quite get there in
season one you know me it was something
that we were investigating and and then
season two it's just it's it's amazing
how much has broken open for her and
also the way that that's been that way
that that's been dealt with it's not
just incidental that she has this arc of
her own and it's finding agency it's
something that everyone has to deal with
in that universe that Arthur has to deal
with his caretaker no longer fulfilling
that role for him that like everyone has
to contend with it and the fact that
there's allowed to be friction and that
she has to sort of persevere through
that I just I love that and I'm so
excited and proud that Ben did that and
that I you know got to get to do that
yeah it was it was it was it was really
awesome and I think exciting in terms of
what what can be done with those
character
within the genre yeah I'm giving you all
what really strong props because I
thought as I said at the beginning I
thought all the storylines for all the
characters were really interesting and
didn't feel like there was a B or C
storyline they just felt all like an a
storyline everything together you know
um I guess I have to ask the most
important question of the people here
because someone here is not being
represented that is danger boat so I
need to ask about first of all John
Martinez of course of course yes very
important yeah but I was seeing lint but
I'm gonna jump in with danger boat real
quick because I believe it was the first
season that people were really enjoying
the arthur danger boat relationship so
how much was that be sort of like
leaning into in the second season
because there's a lot of it and how much
fun is it to play that you know and
write that it's so weird like the people
who watched the show when my friends
watch it their main question is what is
it like working with danger boat and my
answer is it's a set like it's not I
have not met Alan Tudyk
when we're filming I'm looking at
plywood and are like ad is like kind of
going like Arthur please I love you
you know like I'm not I mean it's a
one-sided thing but then it's weird when
you cut it together to dick is giving
such a good performance and the
puppeteering so good the design of the
set is so good but it kind of speaks to
like how weird filmmaking is that it
reads to people as a relationship with
chemistry when it's kind of done in like
separate petri dishes and then all of
them somehow edit together but I think
we were all kind of taken by how
strongly people reacted to that I mean
people feel very emotionally invested in
like that's the now that's the question
I get is like is danger I couldn't get
enough representation and like are you
gonna address the relationship and like
we had like a hard core danger boat
relationship like a bottle episode the
first bottle up so that takes place
inside another character yes and it's
about Erik danger boat is the bottle day
trip what's the bottle yeah when you're
shooting the scenes we had the usually
the second day or no yeah second ad is
reading danger boat signs and it would
alternate each episode would alternate
second ad so you basically had to in my
mind had two different danger boats
depending on what episode would and just
got used to that being the voice and
that being the
which ends up being some of them are
kind of trying to do an Alan Tudyk
impersonation or Connor like they had
seen cease at once so they were trying
to like do their season two they're
trying to kind of do their impression of
it so it was it's it's funny to try to
work with and they're not actors they're
just they're great no disrespect to them
but you know you're doing a different
job than acting that's another funny
thing though is like now we can go into
it and be like oh I know what to Dick's
interpretation of the character sounds
like I can sort of imagine at my head he
got cast late into us filming so all
throughout season when we were like we
have no idea how this is gonna be played
like we know what the dialogue is but we
don't know what kind of voice they're
gonna hire and what their take on the
character is gonna be and it is just
like the things somehow come together I
have a question for you what is it like
being able to turn your head in the
costume can you turn the gun you can
turn your head in the costume yeah can't
you yeah sort of yeah yeah you can but
it's you know it's just I consistently
remind myself that I'm just wearing
normal human clothes you know if ever
I'm feeling in a grump
one day like whose thing I'm wearing
human clothes it puts a spring in my
step I I really want to know now after
this first season when everyone knows
what the costumes gonna look like
although in the second season it changed
a little bit how much for all of you do
you want to go to like the Starbucks
down the street in costume and like you
know just have some fun with it and how
much is it sort of like you are not
allowed to do that
I don't we should eat on location a fair
amount where we're walking around in
those costumes and I've been pretty
amazed how consistently people just
don't care
I'll come I think the first time I came
out of my trailer is there you go this
is gonna be fun and like four families
walked past me like maybe one of them
looked and went I remember filming in
Harlem and this guy
it's says people like just on their way
to work
and most people ignoring me and then one
guy who he looked like he worked for
like The Daily Planet remember like a
trilby on it and he walked past and he
didn't even look he said uh nice costume
tick I remember season what we're doing
the pilot actually we we filmed in a
real apartment for Arthur's apartment
and then later we built a set that
replicated that but we were on like a
third floor walk-up and I was sort of
like sitting in the window trying to get
some air because it was not very well
ventilated and then I saw people across
the street like pointing it like why is
that guy in a bunny suit so then I just
started dancing in the window and I did
it for about 20 minutes and I think like
people were entertained by it but no one
was like what is going on there like
show or something by the headline of
this interview is why the tick is a
webcam section right yeah you know
clickbait I'm all about that on collider
absolutely listen I could ask you guys
seriously a million other questions and
I have a whole bunch but the fact is you
have to do a poster signing so I'm just
gonna say right exactly
- famous for Collider I get the way it
is but and I'll say this on camera I
really love the first eight episodes of
season two I think you guys did such a
great job and I sincerely hope you guys
get to make a since season three you
guys enjoy the signing posters and what
not meeting the fans thank you so much